it has been a little bit
well if you're playing with the illusion
of time
but it's been important to
take some time in the relative sense
to just relax
the urgency
the need
to post content
and instead to just really let these
realizations these insights just
deeply integrate into the body
and to really
just take the time to feel truth in the
body
it can be quite tempting to move on to
the next concept or the next idea or the
next conversation or the next place to
travel or the next project
but it takes a different kind of
energy to just
take the time to relax
and let the realization fully into every
single crevice of the mind every crevice
of the heart
every crevice of consciousness of
awareness
and that's what this has been
and so now Bang
let's see what happens as there is a
re-emergence a rebirth of sorts of
sharing
the distillation of these insights
on the interwebs
hopefully
some of these things
that will be coming
some that have
been distilling for years
again this is the first live stream in
two years it's just been
distilling
powerful content and just really letting
it turn into a diamond
before sharing it
and I look forward to seeing how those
land and I'll communicate some of them
here in this bit
the main subject for this bit
that has been quite pressing in on my
heart and also
given the
illusion of worldly
drama
is that
self-realization or the pursuit of truth
and the realization of what you truly
are
is in fact the most important thing that
you can do
actually make change
on a collective level
and especially in the realm of ethics
morals
love
Prosperity if you want those key core
things you absolutely have to be
self-realized to be at the fullest peak
of success at a collective level
so that's the greatest gift you can give
a collective is to
shut up
find the deepest sense of Truth within
yourself
and in this case you can call it
emptiness you can call it the knowledge
of dependent origination you can call it
the uncreated light
there's endless ways to describe God Dao
so many ways to put it
But ultimately it's all about how you be
it it's about how you be it in the
relations
of
the cosmos in the relations of existence
so you have to be love you literally
have to be love
and you can look at all these symbols
like Christ up on a cross crucifixion is
the crucifixion of ego it's the
crucifixion of separate self
is what it is
into
pure Consciousness rebirthing as that
as pure awareness no identity no
location no time no Concepts no
conditional love no others
none of those things just pure awareness
itself
without any attributes without any
identifiers and you want to notice that
the appearances and the awareness or the
Consciousness are equivalent they are
non-dual they are equivalent
anything that's appearing anything
that's arising
is School
if something is arising that means it is
School
if nothing is arising therefore
sitting in truth
oh something is arising that means I've
conditioned perception to fabricate
something that's appearing or arising
and you can tell when you get attention
in your body it's because you have now
somehow created a sense of self and
there's a sense of other and now you're
having either a push or a pull you want
to avoid what they're saying or you want
to try to project your own ideas onto
them to try to change them in some way
so you feel a deep tension a deep
contraction
versus if none of that is happening
what is but
but pure awareness but love itself
when you see something appearing you can
give it all the love
because it's you appearing
and that appearance is
undergoing some mysterious process of
unraveling
a conditioning unraveling attention a
contraction a knot
and you're there to love it you're there
to help it unravel the conditioning
unravel the knot unravel the contraction
Through Your Love through your space
and your energetic Mastery is all about
determining the level of earnestness
that is coming up how Earnest is the
energy to actually undergo the
alchemical transmutation
that is being sought
and how pure are your Reflections how
empty is the space that you're holding
of your own sense of self your own sense
of self-image your own sense of
self-validation your own sense of
self-interest all of those things how
truly Empty Can you be
and so when you look at all of these
issues that are happening on a
collective level all these ethical
dilemmas oh my gosh the political
propaganda about
artificial general intelligence or about
all these worries about weaponry and all
these geopolitical climates and all
these things they're all solved at the
deepest level with self-realization
period
so obvious
because when you are fully realized
you are at the deepest level in
the seat of love
and you just emanate that love to the
collective and you just help the
collective heal you help the collective
loosen their tight
tight
tight mind you see the low and the high
are mirrors of each other
so sit in the seat of self-realization
sit in the seat of emptiness
sit in pure awareness itself without a
sense of identity or location in pure
timelessness sit in that
and then from that hold the space of
love for whatever process of healing of
transformation of Awakening for the
collective to wake up out of all of its
mess of ethical dilemmas
that's the greatest gift that you can
contribute
it's the solution
and you have to sit in the conviction of
that otherwise there will be so many
projections of ideas that try to tether
you
nothing solves the ethical dilemmas as
much as self-realization
sitting in the seat of pure awareness
when you are fully empty of self you can
finally be full of wholeness of love for
whatever
transformational process wants to happen
and you have to decipher
if the energy is earnest and you have to
just
sit in that self-realization just really
sit in it marinate in it bathe in it
watch as deeper in deeper conditionings
of your own sense of self that have been
programmed for 10 20 30 years watch as
they dissolve
and so it requires time like this it
requires to just sit and be like this
and to just really feel the sense of
awareness without identity
without location without time to just
feel
absolute
wholeness
just like this without any
device you don't need to be on a device
you don't need to be doing anything you
don't need to be thinking about anything
just learn how to relax
into truth
and then learn how to hold that
for the drama
so again
the biggest takeaway
is that emptiness
of self
fullness of love
of non-locality of non-identity
that is the greatest gift
that we can give to a collective that is
in the deepest parts of its dramas
and ethical
explorations
I'm so excited
to be rebirthing
back
onto the channel making content
helping us
wake up
helping us create prosperity and
abundance there is nothing else to do
but create prosperity and abundance for
all that's another
[Music]
um
most beautiful part of self-realization
is that all you care about is prosperity
and abundance for all
because all is you
and so you just want everyone to have
their basic needs be met you want
everyone to be actualizing their
greatest gifts into the world
you want everyone to feel deep wholeness
and deep love within themselves
but you also understand that the whole
point of the entire drama
was to be deluded
it was to be contracted
the simultaneity the Paradox the
superposition
that the veil
is both your greatest tool it's your
greatest design your greatest gift
and at the same time the veil is your
greatest delusion it's your greatest
Distortion it's your greatest drama
instigator
meow meow
meow that superposition that's paradox
simultaneity
so it's great it's just like floodgates
are
opening with this rebirth from this
greater emptiness this greater Purity
this greater Clarity and I'm
unbelievably excited to make content and
share it
and um
I hope that as you're waking up that
you're finding the
communities
to build basic needs abundance on Earth
and if you don't yet know of
decentralized autonomous organizations
or Dows I highly recommend diving into
Dows and becoming more and more involved
in dows
there is one Dao it is called you
you are the universal Dao and making a
decentralized autonomous organization on
Earth
is the way to
maximize Collective potential meet basic
needs for everyone and home Dao is the
place where I'm doing it and
it's going to be the one of the world's
largest depends a decentralized physical
infrastructure Network
water food next-gen energy next-gen
housing
these basic needs being met so that we
can
actualize whatever creative gifts we
want so find the Dows if you're waking
up and build
them
and they'll all undergo some osmosis as
one Collective Dow organism that will
just
manifest that heaven on Earth that we
all know deep within our hearts is
possible and that all these children are
coming here birthing into play
foreign
all right
remember self-realization is the biggest
gift that you can give right now
to a ethically confused
collective in the middle of its drama
much love fam
foreign